well and even more than that I mean that
I've mentioned even in this office you
know the same processes are there we've
done research showing that act and the
processes that underlie it can help
things like can secretaries learn new
software can ferret us learn new methods
what about stigma and prejudice between
people so it isn't just in the
psychotherapy areas and why that would
be as an empirical fact there's a pretty
enormous breadth to these methods and
the why that would be because everywhere
that a human mind goes these processes
of avoiding the world within in order to
try to regulate your behavior or
becoming entangled in your thoughts
interfering with your ability to take
advantage of of what's around you or
losing contact with your values for fear
that you'll know more about the places
where you hurt those kinds of processes
are just normal psychological processes
that are built-in to language and
cognition itself they're built into
problem-solving and so if you take the
mode of mind that works great in 95
percent of your life and apply it within
it then implodes it it starts creating
barriers and that's true at work it's
true in our organizations that's true in
our culture during our politics and yeah
it's true in our consulting rooms so
we're going the reason why it spreads
out we have pretty good evidence for
this I know it sounds a little grandiose
but the mental cognitive processes that
we're targeting are ones that narrow
human beings repertoire and make it
harder for them to learn to be more
flexible to take advantage of the
opportunities in front of them and we
think that's something we can have
something to say about some of the help
within all of these different areas
maybe even in areas like child
development or organizations and schools
or maybe even things like prevention or
how people's interact with each other
one day
other so we've taken the work for
example into things like prejudice and
stigma because in the modern world if we
can't solve that we have planes flying
into buildings and then we have planes
flying over countries you know the
amount of hate and objectification and
dehumanization that's on the planet
isn't something we can tolerate anymore
in a world and that's coming of suitcase
bombs and the ability to amplify that
hate out into harm towards each other so
it applies broadly because anywhere that
human mind goes these processes go